all right a plane crashed in turkey
Texas why you ask apparently the pilot
was flying at a low altitude in order to
drop 350 gallons of pink water when it
slammed into the ground the reason for
the pink water a gender-reveal party for
those unaware a gender-reveal is a
public announcement by parents of their
unborn child sex thankfully no one died
minor injuries we can't say the same for
a 56 year old woman who weeks later was
killed by an explosion that was part of
another gender reveal I saw you yawn
Emily now on the five Iban phrases that
become repetitious at the end of the day
let's unpack this guess what
why oh it's to combat mimesis that you
desire human sounds to imitate the need
to belong leads us to adopt behavior as
we see in other people as a way not to
stand out fitting in keeps you from
getting killed until it kills you
because today most idiotic behavior
seems to get the most attention we see
more people doing dumb things
subconsciously to belong and knowingly
to be noticed idiocy becomes a virus we
saw this with kids in Tide Pods but
adults aren't much better and the media
doesn't help by spreading dumb trends
far and wide and then all you're left
with is a giant mess that other people
have to clean up so instead just pop a
balloon filled with pink or blue glitter
or ask the doctor the gender and keep it
to yourself no one cares besides isn't
gender a social construct anyway who's
to say if it's a boy or a girl ten years
from now
that'll be against the law anyway why do
you agree with me social media makes
everybody dumber but I said when you
said virus I thought that was the
keyword because I think the reason
people do this stupid stuff yeah and so
they can put it on social media right
press their friends yes exactly and I
would guess this was a very rich stupid
person since the gallons Emily because
then it was pink water so that was
supposed to say I guess it was a girl
I'm assuming I don't want to get any
letters a girl but I mean do you think
what's going on here well pink waters
disgusting and also I just I think
everyone has a problem with just enough
like like it's enough to just tell your
friends and family or have a pink cake
or whatever like everything has to be
out done for their personal narcissistic
reasons of because I have to get a ton
of lakes remember that Arizona fire last
year 45,000 acres and eight million
dollars because someone wanted to tell
the world what gender their annoying
yeah that was caused by a gender-reveal
party the fire yes are annoying
shouldn't the data should these people
be sued like what restive deal with this
matter
yeah the farmer from but I'm not much
for extra litigation I don't think
that's necessary but I like I mix I'm
glad that people are excited about their
kids right and I think that's an
exciting thing and they want to really
with people but I also think if I were
to ever have had a baby I like to think
that I would have waited to be surprised
at the birth because I think that's
that's God's gift to you that's a
surprise yeah I guess it's it really
good I'm kidding Jesse you haven't
revealed your gender yet okay I am Pro
gender reveal okay for a few reasons one
silly finding out the gender of your
baby is probably the most thrilling
moment of someone's life it's up there
yeah and having that inconsequential to
ya and then being able to share that
with other people is really fun and
exciting I've never been to a gender
reveal party but if someone invited me
to one I would be there early yeah and
even I don't even need to know these
people I would go to a stranger's gender
reveal party just to be like it's a girl
you know it's exciting also Greg yeah
you're forgetting about the comedy
consequence don't deprive us of comedy
can any bloopers come from gender reveal
show the guy swinging at a baseball
filled with pink or blue he misses hits
himself in the head and falls in the
pool yeah that stuff online is gold yeah
and when I'm online there's only a few
things to do there's fake news and
there's bloopers and that's what I like
a good blooper a good blooper all right
do you want me to read this